What is love? Well,
what do you think this thing is? Uh, like, uh,
our attachment to other human beings.
And is it something that we should give to just a few people? Yes. That's the,
for sure. When I was working with deal Hugo in his book, he didn't use the term,
but he was describing like low key depression and he talked
about how he was in the airport and he noticed a girl had a red dress and he
went up to thanked her and she was like waiting for,
and he had realized he hadn't registered color in like weeks.
And I think love is like that.
When you see someone and you just like, Oh, like,
like your eyes are open. Like this is something I've never seen before.
I want more of this, that kind of thing. It's really, uh,
it really disorients. And reorients your thinking, don't you find that like,
the world is full of that, like nonstop. It's not just like a person either.
It's like, but it, yes. But when it's in a person it's a whole other level,
because it's like, I could have, this is going to be great for years. It's like,
you know, every day it's something new. I mean, that, that is, and that is rare.
You think is where I might find someone who you could talk to them for years and
not run out of things to talk to this show for years. Yes. That's rare.
And know that they really, if you leave the room, they will do right by you.
I that's really rare. Well,
from a Russian perspective, you just don't give them another choice.